Using a Charge Card to Buy $170 Million Painting
Throughout the late 1980s and early 1990s
there was a legend that was passed around
speaking of a special credit card only issued
by American Express to people with more zeroes
in their bank balance than a half eaten bowl
of Cheerios.
This was, of course, not true, or at least
it wasn’t until 1999 when American Express
decided to make the card a reality.
To quote a director for the company, Doug
Smith, “There had been rumors going around
that we had this ultra-exclusive black card
for elite customers.
It wasn’t true, but we decided to capitalize
on the idea anyway.”
Dubbed “The Centurion Card”, this card
is functionally identical to an American Express
platinum card with a few added benefits exclusive
to Amex’s most affluent customers.
We won’t bore you with some of the more
mundane benefits of being rich enough to have
a platinum card, like hotel upgrades and having
most transaction fees waived, because there’s
a much more interesting benefit to talk about-
the 24 hour concierge service.
Yes, the platinum customers have unlimited,
round the clock access to a number they can
call for help doing just about anything.
While on paper the service is supposed to
be used for things like booking hotels or
finding restaurants in a city one is not familiar
with, if the individual is a little more,
shall we say, creative, the service is essentially
a 24 hour personal assistant.
For example, consider the story of internet
prankster John Hargrave, who once tried to
push the limits of a similar service offered
by his Visa Signature Chase card.
Hargrave found that his concierge service
were happy to help him do everything from
book a trip to space to help him with a crossword
puzzle he was stuck on.
However, after asking a representative if
there was something they wouldn’t do, he
discovered it was against Chase’s policy
to use the service to run personal errands,
plan a wedding or help arrange a visit to
a child prostitute…
The company did, however, admit that they’d
be more than happy to help “make an appointment
for a rendezvous at the Bunny Ranch” (a
legal brothel in Nevada), if a customer so
desired it.
Now, keep in mind, this is the level of service
offered by a regular credit card a person
with an average income could afford- so imagine
what kind of things a billionaire with an
uber-exclusive card only granted to the upper
echelons of society can get if they asked.
If you’re imagination isn’t all that great,
according to one executive at Amex asked about
the most outlandish requests the company has
fulfilled, he noted they were once asked to
deliver a handful of sand from the Dead Sea
to London.
The company did this by sending an international
courier to the shores of the Dead Sea on a
motorcycle.
The courier then posted the sand to the customer.
Apparently the sand was to be used in a school
project.
In another case, the cardholder wanted to
appear on a soap opera, but wasn’t sure
how to make this happen.
The Amex representative managed to get the
woman an audition for a role in such a show.
Yet another bizarre request was from someone
wanting Amex to find the horse ridden by Kevin
Costner in Dances with Wolves.
They were not only able to track this down
for the customer (with the horse then residing
in Mexico), but were also able to arrange
for purchase of the animal and then had it
transported to Europe where the customer lived.
In addition to a more tailored, dedicated
concierge service, the Centurion Card comes
with a personal travel agent, automatic access
to a number of high-end clubs for rich people,
and personal shoppers for the most exclusive
stores in the world.
The card also grants extensive travel related
benefits such as free travel insurance, access
to exclusive airport lounges and first class
upgrades on flights with certain airlines.
This might all have you wondering how exactly
you get your hands on such a card and what
the specific requirements are.
Well, nobody outside the company knows exactly.
You see, it’s invitation only and American
Express has never released any official information
about what criteria they use to decide who
is eligible.
This said, the rumour mill has it that if
you really want an invitation for a Centurion
Card there are three basic criteria you need
to fill:
You need to already be an American Express
platinum card holder.
You need to have used that card for at least
a year.
You need to spend on average between $250,000
and $500,000 each year on your card.
As for any overall wealth requirement, there’s
currently no consensus on how wealthy you
need to be to be eligible for the card, though
a commonly quoted annual income is about $1.3
million minimum.
This said, there are reportedly Centurion
Card holders “who merely make mid-six-figure
salaries”, so perhaps they use a flexible
or weighted requirements system (presumably
including net worth and credit score), rather
than a more rigid one mostly based on income
and spending habits.
What is more definitively known is that, once
offered the card, you usually have to pay
a joining fee, plus a rather hefty annual
fee.
While it varies from country to country, for
reference, in the United States it’s a $7,500
joining fee with a further annual charge of
$2,500 for each card holder.
While this is amazingly expensive, if one
travels a lot, the perks of the card, including
that virtual personal assistant, can very
easily make it worth it.
So what can the lucky few who do own a Centurion
Card buy with it?
Well, to put it simply, anything they want.
According to American Express executives,
the card’s limit is effectively infinite
and only bound by the holder’s individual
wealth.
To this end, the card’s actual limit is
decided by a comprehensive analysis of the
holder’s spending habits and net worth.
As for the most extravagant thing ever purchased
using one, that is probably the Amedeo Modigliani
painting Reclining Nude which was purchased
by Chinese billionaire, Liu Yiqian, in 2015.
The total cost?
$170 million…
And, yes, he put it on his card.
This was actually the second time he’d used
his card for such an expensive object around
this time, previously paying $36 million for
a tea cup that dated back to the Ming Dynasty.
As if being able to pay for a $170 million
painting (among many other large purchases)
with a an Amex wasn’t ridiculous enough,
Yiqian has also earned perhaps the most charge
card reward points of anyone in history, with
his wife noting they had enough points to
fly the family in luxury for free for the
rest of their lives.
However, apparently one can also use the points
to buy luxury items, such as a 26-carat diamond
bracelet that goes for a mere 33 million rewards
points…
Of course, the points weren’t the only reason
he put the painting and other such expensive
items on his charge card, instead of paying
cash.
You see, China has restrictions on how much
money an individual can transfer out of country
per year at around the equivalent of $50,000.
Needless to say, for a billionaire with expensive
tastes, this is extremely restricting when
wanting to buy something out of country.
By using the card, it circumvents this restriction
completely as his card was issued through
the bank of China.
So he’s paying them back, not sending money
out of country himself.